(bourdonnements)
ElElles bourdonnent,
produisent du miel comme toutes
les abeilles, mais celles-ci
Fanny Arguijo parle avec
une affection maternelle
de ses abeilles mélipones,
Melipona beecheii, plus
standards qui ne semblent
pas très dérangées quand
on ouvre leurs ruches.
Cette abeille, élevée depuis
des millénaires par les Mayas,
était en voie de disparition.
- Mais là, on a différentes
- Sa renaissance, on la doit
en grande partie à ce çaçaçais
passionné d'apiculture depuis
son enfance. Établi
au Mexique, deveenenenenenenener
de la fameuse abeille maya.
Il se met a a a recherche.
Pas facile.
STÉPHANE PALMIERI,
apiculteur et hôtelier
- Sur tout le territoire
de Tulum, on avait trouvé
Donc, il y a une dizaine
d'années. Juste trois colonies
qui étaient en tronc
et c'étaient des papys
qui avaient ça depuis
- Les ruches sont à l'arrière
de son hôtel, au mi
d'une végétation foisonnante.
Avec sa fondation,
Melipona Maygégégégégégégégégég.
- Je vais ouvrir celles-là.
Les autrleleleles sont pas
mal aussi. L'idée, c'était
de reproduire des colonies pour
aiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiae
génétique un peu conséquent.OnOt
des colonies qu'on a distribuées
dans les communautés mayas.
se nomme xunán kab,
littéralement la vraie dame.
- Elles sont belles.
Elles sont toutes calmes avec
cette espèce... cette abeille-
elles savent qu'on
n'est pas une menace.- - - - -Çu
cosmique, un peu cosmovision
de la... mais c'est joli!
- De là à dire que les anciennes
civilisations mayas ont copié
la structure du
des abeilles en érigeant
leurs pyramides, les mélipones
ont eu, alalalalalalalalalalalat
la mythologie des civilisations
ma M M M M M M M M M M M M M M é
des abeilles. On peut voirsa ree
de Tulum, tête vers le bas.
On l'appelait le dieu
de l'énergie vitale associée
à la fécondité, bienveillant,
pacifique comme les abeilles
Melipona, également divinité
de l'écriture, du calendrier
et surtout de la médecine.
- Dans la tradjojojojojojojojojs
utilisé du miel des Melipona.
Il le dommmmmmère pendant
l'accouchement, plus tard,
elles le donnent au bébé. Donc,
illelelelelelelelelelelelelelele
une série de préparations.     ♪
- La renaissance de l'abeille
a a a a a a vite intéressé
l'Université interculturelle
maya de Felipe Carrillo Puerto.s
de l'université où
l'enseignement se fait en maya.
♪ ♪ ♪
Non loin, dans le parc,x x x x t
bien-aimée où se trouvent lesrut
exploitées par les anciens
Mayas. Aurora Xolalpa dirige
les mélipones et de formation
d'apiculteurs.
Les mélipones sont
des abei
des abeilles tropicales
et en Amérique centrale,
le monde des Mayas
Ceux-ci l'ont répandue jusqu'à
Cuba, mais on trouve aussi
de cette sAuAuAuAuAuAuAuAuAuAuA.
Les mélipones diffèrent
sensababababababababeille la
plus courante, l'Apis mellifera.
On reconnaît les ouvrièresinini.
Le miel se trouve dansamamamama.
Le miel se trouve dans
omomomomomomomombées.
On peut le voir en les perçant.
En quelques secondes,e e e e e .
Autre particularité :ararararare
de la ruche qui s'écartequququq.
Le retour à la ruche des
abeilles qui ont été dérangéesss
de la mélipone, de son mielet ds
sont issues des premières
reproducti
s'intéresse à d'autres
variétés de mélipones.
- Mais il nous manque énormément
- Sur tout ce qui est abeille. s
la caractérisation du miel
de Melipona, donc...l'explorer a
où on finit de construire
le plus grand centre
de recherche apicole
d'Amérique latine.
On s'apprête à recevoir
le matériel des labora
qui se consacreront aux analyses
et des salles de classe.
Fanny Aguado, qui a été formée ,
mais il faut se contenter d'unee
production d'un litre par ruche
par année, contre 35 litres
avec quatre récoltes par an.
Ce miel est évidemment
beaucoup plus cher.
L'agronome Rocio Vidal dit quels
riche, un peu plus acide, plus
liquide. Sa saveur varie selon
selon les régions.
ononononononononononon miel surs
sortes de miel en évitantles in.
L'inconvénient : son prix.
Mais il
Cet apiculteur vend son propre
mis s s s s s s s s s s s s s ss
très peu de miel de mélipones.
Il est au moins cinq fois plus
cher. Le miel de mélipones doit
des contrefaçons par une sorte
d'appellation cont
biologique. Il faut aussi faire
connaître sa valeur culturelle
et patrimoniale millénaire.
Autre menace pour la mélipone,
commune à toutes
les cultures transgéniquesetetet
des sommets inquiétants
dans